hello freak [ __ ] that's what that's
my fundamental orientation and so or my
fundamental concern I mean I don't
expect people to be a hundred percent
honest because of course who is you know
I mean that's a hell of a the kind of
standard I hold anyone to but all about
is smoke and mirrors and I think the
people who are after me know it
Alyssa let's get through some of that
just to just to sort of establish it for
people maybe they don't know what issues
do you have any issue whatsoever with
some being transgender no I don't have
any issue with that what I have an issue
with is that is that I don't like to see
the postmodern neo-marxists use the
transsexual issue as a lever for pushing
forward their political nonsense and I
said that right from the beginning and
in the videos I made to begin with the
reason I wouldn't use the word Z and
Zurn is and all those other made-up
words however many there are now is
because I'm not willing to cede the
linguistic territory to postmodern
radicals I'm not doing that and they say
well we're doing it on behalf of the
oppressed transsexual people and I think
yeah well that's what you say but
there's no reason I should believe they
don't believe anything you say I think
you're contemptible cowardly
ideologically motivated cult-like
corrupters of the youth so why would I
use your language well let's unpack that
because one of the things that I find
fascinating is how few transgender
people want to use those words the
transgender people seem to want to
identify with whatever gender they like
if if you are a male to female
transgender person you would prefer to
be called ashy right like Caitlyn Jenner
right right and pretty much everybody
calls the the artist formerly known as
Bruce Jenner Caitlyn Jenner right that's
that's just it's that I give you at a
look at how many people just openly
accept that's pretty it's it's pretty
well accepted right most transgender
people prefer that they prefer female to
male I prefer they prefer to be a man
now I'm a man now okay Bob dick whatever
your name is
that's in there's not a lot of Z's or 12
it may be I'm out of the loop no you're
not out of the loop the other thing is
those are all third-person pronouns it's
like I know I'm not going to call you a
third person pronoun
sitting here you know I never would if
I'm referring to you when I'm talking to
someone else on a name right well I
could use your name your aim I might use
he then but I don't know well right just
all of it is palpably absurd I think
it's always hard to get the level of
analysis for this sort of issue correct
you know because the people who are
pushing it forward say well we're
against harassment and and
discrimination and and they attribute
all the moral virtue to themselves but
then what I see is that they're
utilizing a group a very small minority
group who already have enough problems
in my estimation for for nothing other
than straightforward political purposes
I don't buy the the warm-hearted you
know all inclusive love that the people
who are pushing this sort of thing
forward claim to display I don't see
that at all I what I see mostly is
resentment and the desire to undermine
and I'm quite familiar with the
postmodern philosophy not as familiar as
I could be and also reasonably familiar
with its underlying Marxism and there's
nothing touchy-feely about any of that I
can tell you the postmodernist the best
you can do with post modernist
philosophy is emerged nihilistic that's
the best the worst case is that you're a
kind of anarchical social revolutionary
that's directionless except that you
want to tear things apart or or that you
end up depressed which i see happening
to students all the time because the
post modernists like rip out the
remaining structures of their
foundations of their ethical foundations
so just to be really clear for anybody
tuning in your issues are absolutely not
with someone who identifies with a
gender other than their biological
gender as long as they're not using that
to to promote a political agenda and but
I don't care about the gender thing that
sucks doesn't mean anything well it's
someone it's it's a personal preference
it's a personal issue right personal
issue a personal issue and and I would
also deal with it on an individual to
individual basis as it varies just as
much as they're extremely masculine men
extremely feminine women and there's a
broad spectrum of human beings in
between and each one should be dealt
with on an individual basis yes based on
what they want
but when you're talking about these
made-up words what it seems like is that
some people trying to push these made-up
words and turn them mainstream now the
question is what's the motivation behind
that is this a necessary thing are there
so many people that are of a sexual or
of some sort of mean what would be a Z
Orser what is that supposed to be is
that supposed to be a male or a female
is it supposed to be asexual or is it
supposed to be a non conformist I mean
what is it well it's supposed to be
someone who whose gender isn't specified
right who is neither male nor female
or maybe they say they say technically
in the policy guidelines is anywhere or
nowhere on the spectrum and that's
actually in the policy guidelines in
Ontario where or nowhere right and the
nowhere I mean these are these are
policies that are going to determine law
right that within which the law is going
to be interpreted I don't even know what
nowhere on the spectrum means I don't
understand what that means doesn't mean
anything it's what all sense it's
nonsense so you have so here's the
options right there's someone who
identifies with the opposite gender of
their biological birth so there's a man
Nessa for instance who identifies as a
woman everyone's cool with that whatever
your name is whatever you would like to
be called whether it's Wendy or Mike or
whatever it is that would be the noise
that you want people to make with their
mouth that means you that's it right now
whether you're a he or a she outside of
that that's where things get squirrely
so third-person is the only issue the
only issue is like say if we were
talking to Jamie Jamie just decided to
he's gonna be Jamie now he's still Jamie
Jamie's a girl's name - I know girls
named Jamie so he could be Jamie and
Jamie decides he's a woman and now he
wants to be called she work okay okay
she all right Jamie
now you're she but when it gets to like
zarur
and Z and the 78 different gender
pronouns it seems to a person outside of
it person who's cisgendered it seems
pretty pretty
are and it seems pretty preposterous and
it seems pretty indulgent and it seems
like there's something else going on in
this well that's the thing it's
something else going on part that is
what concerns me there is something else
going on it if there wasn't something
else going on a relatively obscure
professors amateurish YouTube videos on
a relatively obscure piece of Canadian
legislation wouldn't have had any effect
right it would have just disappeared
what it didn't but and that's because
there's more going on than the
straightforward issue surrounding the
pronoun use and everybody knows it for
everybody feels it at least well what it
seems like from someone is outside of
academia someone like me it seems like
you're pushing back against something
that they are really trying hard to
establish and then it's some kind of
control it's some kind of control with
how people behave and communicate and
it's not it's not like a societal thing
it's a very small isolated group of
people that seem to be trying to
indoctrinate others into their ways and
they become they're becoming very vocal
and very angry and innocent like
verbally violent about your opposition
to they're controlling the way they can
meet that other p.m. well they don't
like me poking holes in their ideology
and
[Applause]
[Music]